撮合作业的时间
以及公布注意交易资讯的标准
8月10号正式实施
面对近期台股大喜三温暖
立委王世坚炮轰制度落伍
投资人蒙心肝想看看
针对不符十一的股票处置制度
证交所最新公布
缩短处置期间
一般处置包括第一次及第二次以上
发布处置股
从关10天变成关5天
当冲过高处置股
从原本12个营业日改成7天
普通的交易撮合时间
不管是5分钟还是20分钟
统统加快
改成每2分钟撮合一次
原来的规定是
第一次处置是5分钟
第二次处置是20分钟
那现在余率呢
缩改为2分钟
也同时放宽千金股的注意触发标准
从原本的价差门槛100元
改成当天收盘价超过1000元
6个营业日价差达到300元以上才适用
也调整急剧标准
每增加1000块
价差标准增加150元
而谈到近期提出的熔断机制
证交所也有相关说明
美国是没有涨跌幅的限制
那韩国是涨跌幅是30%
那台湾涨跌幅只有10%
我们并没有要采取熔断机制
不靠熔断
靠改变储置股关禁闭时间
改挫和时间来冷却
但被质疑到底有无人为盖牌
相关融资维持率
证教所也说
一切都是资讯透明
绝对没有人为干预
可以在我们的官网上面看到
所有监视的标准
不管是当冲比例
不管是等等的各种数字
涨跌等等
通通都是有数字做佐证的
所以绝对没有人为裁量这种事情
全民封台股证教所紧急召开记者会
从8月10号开始
新智就会上路
30年来首次修正
强调不是因为受到近期市场压力才更动
而是已经讨论长达半年
未来也会每半年定期检视机制
因应市场变化提出措施
东森财新闻成为王家庄长君台北长报道
台股迎来8月的第一个交易日
大盘开低翻红
盘中一度上涨超过600点
中场是收在43386点
利首43k
联发科日月光还是涨停所死
往下再往上台股又开始搭云霜飞车吗
7月的最后一天才刚暴力反弹
8月第一个交易日开低后迅速翻红
一度上涨664点
占上43,784点
中场上涨266点
收在43,386点
力手43K
AI的趋势还是很好
那第二个就是Fed9月如果不升息
那我们看第四季的话
就是AI的IPO相关的题材支持
那我们看在最快在第四季呢
有机会创新高
甚至有机会上看5万点
調至1萬元
更帶動偽創黑翻紅收漲超過半根
台積電的一個漲停
其實給予市場信心很大的一個修復
至少大盤指數在4萬2以下
已經先打出了第一隻腳
大家最愛的記憶體在上演漲停秀
南亞科華邦店望紅預創都亮燈
被動元件翻身的機會來了
MLCC龍頭春田調高猜測
上半年一天賺一億的國具
再亮一顆燈
華興科日電帽 信唱電
密旺石也都收在漲停
泰國後世怎麼走
美國將公布7月非農就業報告
失業率數據
成為FED會後首場大考
加上SpaceX 超委
Sandisk都將公布財報以及川普要重新跟伊朗談判中東局勢也成為牽動全球金融市场的重要变数东南财经新闻台北报道往下再往上台股又开始搭云霄飞车吗
7月的最后一天采钢暴力反弹
8月第一个交易日开地后迅速翻红
一度上涨超过600点就是要首尾43K关卡
积极撑盘的联发科跟日月光
罚收行情持续延烧双双强更涨停
其中美希外资还把发个目标价调到7000元
虽然台积电小跌拉回整理
不过根据历史经验
在神山涨停后
大盘连续5天10天20天上涨的几率超过5成
加上筹码清洗干净
市场焦点回归基本面等
无大利多接连发小
台积电的一个涨停
其实给予市场信心很大的一个修复
至少大盘指数在4万2以下
已经先打出了第一只脚
月季线目前的位置大概是在4万4千点左右
這個位置點如果能夠站上的話
整個修正的一個趨勢
才會扭轉過來
台北後市怎麼走
美國將公布七月非農就業報告
事業率分析
還要提供到年限的一個股票
比比皆是
所以短線的本來就具備
跌升反彈的一個條件
台北後市怎麼走
美國將公布七月非農就業報告
失業率分析
所以現在是在台北後市
台北後市怎麼走
美國將公布七月非農就業報告
失業率分析
所以在台北後市
台北後市怎麼走
美國將公布七月非農就業報告
将公布7月非农就业报告
失业率数据
成为FED会后首场大考
加上SpaceX超维
Sandisk都将公布财报
以及川普要重新跟伊朗谈判
中东局势也成为
牵动全球金融市场的重要变数
东文财政新闻台会报道
目前来看的话
我先讲结论
就是恐慌的部分
在上礼拜已经陆续的结束了
那我们认为指数未来
会出现震荡走高的一个态势
当然它不是天天的一个大涨
而是以震盪走高
就是近三推二或者是近三推一的模式
出現了震盪走高的一個格局
那當然現在來看的話
最主要是因為
全球股市都在看南韓
那南韓你可以看到
在上禮拜五的大漲之後
那目前來講
他是有出現小幅度拉回的一個走勢
不過我認為
這不礙於未來的一個反彈的格局
那另外的
南韓股市
當然看三星跟海力士的部分
所以我們可以看到
就是說為什麼會覺得
南安股市他還是有機會震盪走高
最主要是因為
南安股市今年GDP的預估
大概有3%的成長
去年只有一%
所以他當然出現
第二個是海利市目前的本益比
大概只有5倍左右
大家試想5倍是真的蠻低的
所以
我們覺得南安股市震盪走高
全球的股市就有機會向上走穩的
那另外的部分來講
我們可以看到熱門的族群
那當然記憶體的部分
你可以看到海利市
雖然今天海利市拉回
不過上週五 海力士 三星等等
這些股票
都出現了大漲的一個走勢
所以激勵了
南亞科 華邦店等等這些的股票
另外的載板的部分來講
一筆等 雖然今天小福拉回
不過在上禮拜有大漲之後
其實整個買盤來講
還是聚焦在所謂
新興 南電 景碩等等這些的股票
因為畢竟這些股票之前真的跌滿深的
撥欠布的部分來講也出現了反彈
那當然撥欠布看日東訪
日中坊當然也帶動了
像台波富橋等等這些的股票
另外的被動元件看春田
那國巨華新科也經過之前的大跌之後
這兩天也都出現強勢的漲勢
低軌道衛星的部分也聚集了人氣
你可以看比如說像華通
聲達科聲茂等等
這些股票今天的表現
相對上來講蠻強勢的
那我覺得未來來講的話
其實大家可以聚焦在
哪些的個股身上
比如說今明年成長性高的就是營收跟獲利數字至少YOY成長20%以上的那這個就有機會成為戴維斯雙級的個股對 像是今天我們可以
觀察到大盤像載板指標股
星星啊 景碩開盤帶量上漲
被動元件國際
今天又拉第二根漲停了
那到底會衝到哪裡呢
而且之前你剛剛提到的包括像是今天
多檔漲停之前跌升的
如今有F轉我們該跑還是續追呢
對 沒錯我覺得
我覺得這一塊來講的話
其實這些的股票
因為之前股價真的跌幅蠻重的
很多都超過五成以上
那目前來講的話
因為剛剛提到的這些的
國際的指標已經開始走穩了
所以我覺得這些股票
假如你是持有的人
我認為他的股價還會持續的
震盪走高的態勢
或許會有短線上的一個賣壓出龍
不過我們覺得波段來講的話
他還是有去創這一波段
就是新高的一個機會
那當然你想要為持有的人
我覺得你可以等待拉回來之後再去做買信
不管是被動元件或者是記憶體的部分
或載板等等
龙头连巴克目前也是锁住涨停的
那被动元件众所瞩目
国具今天也拉到了552块的涨停价
所以在这个族群当中
目前至少有看到了五档的涨停
那为什么被动元件今天反弹的力道会这么强呢
就是因为全球MLCC的龙头春田调高了财测
合并纯益呢
调升到了3380亿日元
调升幅度高达15%
所以市场也预期说
台湾厂商的被动元件
应该在接下来公布营收
也都渴望有带来
这个还不错的营收表现
那除了这个被动元件之外
目前网上拉高的
还有在载版族群
包含了现在有看到了
星星也攻上了涨停
以及封侧龙头的日月光
也在这个610块的
涨停版的价格
但是还是要提醒大家
因为目前日本股市
韩国股市都还是在盘下震荡
南韩股市目前甚至跌4%
三星跟SK海力市目前股价也跌7%
所以亚洲市场现在呈现比较不同调的态势
那台股有没有办法自行的独挑大梁
都是今天的观察重点
再把时间交往给进
台股周五暴涨3186点
原本想说纸商可以拿来回收了吗
恐怕先别急
因为周五台指企业盘又跳水下错了1077点
就让不少股民苦叹
难道周一又要再度回公园了吗
明明受到科技财报力多
周五每股四大指数都收红
怎么台股夜盘却逆势重挫
最低还一度要跌破四万二
没趁周五反弹人到走廊逃命
周一是否真要挫雷蛋
想必周五才刚因为一亿零零五零
账面大赚超过一千万却没卖的郭哲荣
肯定要被关心几句
我手真的完全不担心
我睡得蛮好的
礼拜一我觉得会稍微开低一些
但可能不一定想
大家想那么严重
要选择可以睡得到的部位
如果那你睡不好的部位
那该检马就检马
或者心态要改变
点出风掌后回档很正常
基本面没出现重大转折
就不该脑冲乱砍
而是要太弱补强
有机会开低走高
我觉得明天有机会
跌点收敛
甚至跌点到500点
是300点练
甚至有机会挑战旁中翻红
当然我觉得这边拉回
我觉得稍微进展做多
不过也有投资人抱怨
很常跌停想止损挂卖却卖不掉
其实是因为不少被打成
储置股关禁币延迟交易
就让王世坚开批
30年前台股所适用储置制度
跟目前市场根本严重脱节
因为政府的储置导致它卖不掉
让它跌得更深的时候那股民他們的怨嘆當然怪罪的對象唯一就是怪罪政府認為應該用熔斷機制
取代分盤交易
不該干預市場流動性
點出在股市震盪時
政府不送暖
至少也別再添亂
Dosan Lucia
林豪榮 李仁峰
台北參謀道
攝影師 起來起來
快看手機
台股31號
迎來3186點
驚天暴漲
來來來
公園解散
今晚加菜
哲哲道歉表
也拿去
因為他是不是幾天前
就跟你說過這一句
好 我接受你的道歉
但是請記得我名言
All in 中壓就是現在
社群狂被洗版
不是沒原因
投顧老師郭哲榮
在台股五個交易日
跌掉近五千點時
30號這息話
你有沒有聽
我恳求你們
再給自己最後一次
愛哲哲的機會
現在買
All in 現金
All in
全押 我知道你還有錢
叫人家All in
更要以身作折
自稱螳螂黨局
29號直接砸一億
買0050
這精神狀態
團結
信心
濟利
我希望你們
通通踏着我的血前进
是的 哲哲团长这回真胜利
晒队账单29号0050分别买在93.45元和93.2元
共1100张成本约1.02亿
31号0050直接涨停
今天涨停板4%刚好就赚1000万
对比两天前衣服红了 红酒开了
当时荡掉的表也回来了
一战成名直播观看人数比平常多了4到5倍
这个我一次爱哲哲的机会
男粉丝其实很多喜欢另外一句名言
就是说反正命一条冲就对了
不过从盘面看反弹3000多点
量却只有8000多亿
就有另一派分析师直言
这是开人道走廊
3000多点恐怕下周就吐回去
而对于刚赚1000万的哲哲来说
还是只有这一句
今年就会上5万点
明年突破6万点
然后4到5年内突破10万点
东盛鲁鲁鲁鲁台北
从不得
太阳高高挂 阳光耀眼照得红彤彤
台股也一扫阴霾 狂亮红灯
IC设计龙头连发科 气势如虹
在法说会前夕冲涨停
神山台积电更一度占上2400
上涨195点
广达鸿海涨幅也多4%以上
台股大盘在7月最后一个交易日
盘中涨了将近3000点
超越今年5月4号
写下史上盘中最大涨点
市值一下增加超过9兆元
解铃还需细铃人
今天韩国它涨到垄断
带动整个雅谷的一个反弹
台股这一波的融资余额也轻了蛮多的出来
4900亿左右也低于5000亿
今天的报复性反弹
我想延续两到三天的机会是有的
满血复活的还有还有
前两天重挫的族群
像是记忆体的南亚科华邦店
本地基電 望紅 早盤同步攻上漲停
載版三雄 新興南電和景碩
也都紅通通
至於差一點完成聖誕樹的
被動元件龍頭國具也亮燈漲停
跳回五字頭
而ETF腰蜘金木也回來了
00981A和00991A也一度漲停
盤面氣氛明顯回溫
像CCL或者載版
他們的事況還是明顯的
今年都還是供不應求的情況
甚至个股它越跌本益比越好
这样的话可以去做持股续报
甚至有拉回再做加码的动作
因为大盘涨而跟着涨
然后再去找它涨价新闻的一些个股族群的话
可能就不一样了
比如说像公立元件或者说是其他称光的族群
观察事况AI产业订单在没有砍单
没有取消也没有地盐情况下
基本面持续看多
台湖不但一吐怨气
还能继续扬眉吐气
东森采集新外博照片留言
在台湖岛